unknown to explain the meaning to the
treat of entropy she is why is tangent
cotangent etc of let me clean it there
are lots of ways to explain it and
they're not all the same it this way
that I'm about to show you I think it's
the one that's remedy with me the best
so you can decide for yourselves by in
business whether you like your
explanation there are other ones that I
just run with this so I've actually draw
some unit circle I'm just going to start
with my first one because you'll see why
my second one is majolica we know that
there is really one tree ratio that is
the of the granddaddy of them all where
all the rest of the definition is a
which is the which is the basis in which
function it's that the the main one is
really designed everything else is to
find from site okay why is sign called
sighs yeah okay at sign in short a
sinusoidal way which really does mean
it's a curved shape because our but that
so really it has to do with the tape
when you graph right so that shape there
right that's what gives sign is made at
least this way I can sound bigger now we
never say okay we can also define so I'm
looking to the triangle only but also on
the unit circle so if we pick a spot
like today I get back here if we think
about it then we can measure the angle
from the positive x-axis after this call
that be on so I'm going to do that you
should do it soon
and now on the unit circle I can define
the coordinates of that point on the
circumference in terms of the trig
ratios right so firstly we can find what
is signs on this particular where is it
it's the y-coordinate right there's like
how high up you are okay so I'm just
gonna like the corner document so you
just said it's a wine cordon so that's
the second despair what's the
x-coordinate is cosine right so a
constant of size M and so we define
configure to be the equina of the unit
circle where you are and same thing we
defined to be the y-coordinate so we
stop peeking out triangles you can
arrange I don't enjoy my triangle yet
you don't need to triangular to define
what those are either but remember that
this is a radius 1 I can construct that
triangle and it gives you another way of
visualizing what is going on that'll be
the key as you see as you progress
through so side for instance if it's a
y-coordinate then the length that it
corresponds to is actually this leg here
to go from the x-axis off for me we
vertically at that position so I wanted
to draw I've got a couple of colors here
this is very neutral if you do have
colors if you don't you'll survive but
suppose we clear up I'm gonna do side in
blue okay so that this guy here
if the y-coordinate is find that that
means this length TR inside there okay
zero point whatever it happens to be in
exactly the same way I can can shop on
you where cosine the bidder is the
export the solution I know what the end
answers from the origin to this point
over here like so so this red length T
is closed then we have successfully
formed that right angle triangle upon
which one trig function ratios begin but
now I hear they're really tough abit
right I'm actually going to release
color is sine theta is opposite fear
okay so okay because sine theta is
opposite over hypotenuse after all and
the hypotenuse is just one but that
means I can describe the other the final
angle in this triangle as the complement
of fear and that's where cosine get to
say it's the complement of science so
this angle up here being the condoms BR
if 90 degrees minus theta degree that's
what compliment sleep so let's actually
put value and I'm going to have in
colors mention I've got 90 degrees minus
theta up there in the course so what I
want you to pay close attention to you
could go around there but I think it
will become very messy very time what I
want you to notice is sighs we are in of
the theta cos theta is opposite cause
the complement of data there's a basis
sign with feet are culpable side with
the complement of theta okay does that
make sense you see how and we wrote a
definition for this track the condom
value might be our insight it's related
if you don't need the sine rule Vietnam
in a right angle triangle and we are we
starting with that when you
not manic insurance